as you can see sound is a really
important part of any project especially
games take for example half-life 2
someone out there actually made an
entire mod pack to replace the sounds of
the original game so instead of hearing
footsteps you heard duck quacks instead
of searing the missile hitting the alien
you actually heard a crowd laughing the
result was pretty offsetting you didn't
really feel like you were connected in
the environment the drama was gone the
suspense was gone really wasn't the same
game now it's also worth pointing out
that sound design is often one of the
more expensive parts of production it's
long tedious work and often tied very
closely to the design of the game take
for example quake 1 when your quad
damage was running out the designers
decided that you would get a 3 second
pulse warning you that it was about to
run out now if you actually look at the
code they coded in the bright flashes
that you see once every second however
the sound itself was actually a 3 second
clip with the pulses if the artists or
the designers came back and actually
decided they wanted a different length
shorter or longer the sound would have
to be started from scratch this is why
sound design is usually really expensive
for video games and left to the end most
of these changes happen very iteratively
so you have to end up scrapping a lot of
work you've been doing